bonjour c'est Pascal Dumont à l'appareil
bonjour Pascal Dumont à l'appareil c'est
Pascal Dumont à l'appareil félicitations
monsieur RAC vous avez été tiré au sort
vous avez gagné un dîner exceptionnel
avec Eddie chez vous dans votre
salon il suffit de vous présenter ce
vendredi chez S avec votre petite
[Musique]
famille bonjour monsieur vous êtes tout
seul monsieur RAC je ne vois pas votre
petite famille c'était compliqué
aujourd'hui les consignes sont très
claires de famille pas d'action cadeau
ok 150 € on va d'abord au non d'abord
lece
ouvre plus m'appeler je pas je suis là
Michel quoi kine c'est mon voisinvez vu
exemple parfait du parasite surtout pas
perdre de temps avec ce genre de
gugus
capit n'prochez pas il a plus rien ici
tout est désolé moi j'ai gagné ce
concours
j'ai tu veux aller à Brest avec un
sommet non tu déconnes il faut qu'on
ressemble à une vraie famille on a de
jours pour ressembler à
ça une vraie famille ça se fait pas en 2
jours hein une famille c'est organique
c'est dans de sang
Michel tu peux pas tricher avec
ça
non c'est comme la vie quand tu
t'arrêtes d'avancer tu tombes tuas un
tpéo Michel je m'appelle Kin mon père
s'appelle Michel je m'appelle Michel le
gamin s'appelle Michel je sais pas ce
qu'ils ont les Belges avec les petits
gamins mais c'est le vre au
moins parce que un Belge moustach qui
conduit une camionnette moi je me méfie
hein je déconnais de l'humour